I would Partners on
immediately because he's a newspaper
publisher and it is crazy uh it's crazy
what they're trying to do to him it's
completely any American I would Pop I
would pardon Snowden because
what Snowden did for the American people
was to you know help restore at least
some semblance of democracy and the
importance of the uh
information he released
was so it's so it's a tested to the fact
that Congress passed legislation uh
recognizing you know the disclosures
that he had and making sure that you
know to try to make sure that those kind
of abuses didn't occur again so I think
he is a hero not uh he shouldn't be
treated as a villain